oh
and uh we had the woman of the hour with
Christian let's go for it Rochelle uh
big victory for you against one of your
good friends uh Jenny for you now how
does that feel we had a discussion here
on the panel how do you feel after you
play against your best friends
um I mean like I like I don't
I don't know like it's
um it feels good to win but at the same
time like I um sympathize for her so
like because I know if it were in my
shoes I would not be that happy to lose
so absolutely a difficult uh moment but
still that takes you to four out of six
a very respectable uh result for you
let's take a look at today's game take
us through the critical moments it did
feel like she surprised you out of the
opening was that the case
um
I mean I think I don't think she was
expecting
um E5 after C4 actually
um I think that would we might have both
been out of theory I'm not sure because
we both started thinking pretty early on
um
and did you remember this line did you
study this line with your coach not
really
um I think I looked at it really quickly
and because like I was looking at a lot
of things it was she plays like many
things as white so I didn't like really
focus on one thing in particular I just
like reviewed a lot of things
let's keep going Queen to E2 and she was
uh really putting a lot of pressure on
the king side did you feel that way as
well were you concerned at all about
this Pawn push I was a little bit
concerned about G4
like not not here but like eventually uh
I don't think I should have played B6
actually
um maybe if I just like went Bishop D7
immediately
because
I didn't like
I didn't really have a solid plan here I
wanted to possibly put my Bishop on B7
and go C5 eventually and get the bishop
to C6 right yeah
but like I feel like it never really
works like if I move my Bishop to the
um to B7 she has like Knight F5 stuff
and it's actually really annoying to
deal with
and this was the critical moment I think
um not Bishop to B7 but how you uh
played in the game Bishop to D7 and now
she played this move Knight to B3 we
were a bit surprised yeah I was
surprised too I thought maybe we should
go Knight F3 and then Knight E5
um and that was in fact the best movie
in the position yeah
um I think maybe she was like scared of
stuff like Bishop G4
and then
like it probably does not work but it's
like
it's kind of where you some to be honest
like if you take
um Knight takes no it's definitely yeah
um
like Knight takes G3
I know I would be a little bit concerned
if I were white here
no there's a lot of nights around yeah
the white king okay so
um after she played Knight B3
I've played C5 because
um
I completely forgot about Bishop takes
F6 immediately I thought she was gonna
play like Bishop E5 and then I was gonna
play Rook takes E5
um and I thought that position would be
like interesting
you're definitely getting a lot of play
for us yeah
but yeah I just complete like right when
I played I was like wait I should take
my knight immediately but C5 in fact it
was the basketball wait really by far in
the position yes so take on F6 G takes
F6 and this position already the engine
was saying that it's favorable to you
did you feel that way no
I thought I was like um trying to defend
at this point like
I
thought that instead of taking on e4 she
might play Queen H5
um I was kind of worried about this
position wait but do you have Knight
takes G3 is that a move um I thought
King takes Rook takes E3 King F2
and you don't have Queen takes F4 is
that what is enough
it looks so dangerous though
Bishop F3 Bishop C6
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah maybe it's enough maybe Rook to E8
doesn't give you
enough compensation even there
very scary stuff in this position for a
white so let's go back
she took on e4 she decided to eliminate
that night
and uh I want to take you to the moment
after Bishop takes H3
I was not sure about Bishop takes H3 at
all but like what was your concern right
now what was the the move that you were
concerned about I also a little bit
concerned about G4 G4 okay I like I I
didn't see anything after it
but I was like this is kind of scary
um definitely looks scary but actually
G4 was fine for you now yeah the only
move for her was in fact
came to h8 yes E5
did you spot this move
Bishop G4 Knight E4
well like
I think I thought I had the queen takes
D1 yes yes 61 and now the question is
how is the same game after Knight takes
F6
and queen takes D1 and it did seem that
white has enough compensation
maybe not even compensation
yeah
still wild stuff and she played this
move F5 did she just simply Miss Bishop
takes F5 did you no she definitely saw
it because she spent a lot of time there
that's what we thought but it didn't
make a lot of sense
because now after Bishop takes F5 you
just defend yeah
and your two pawns out I mean she wasn't
like heavy time pressure so I don't
really blame her
let's keep going and after that
smooth uh conversion at least that's how
it felt for us
Rochelle big victory for you four out of
six Sophie seems to be going to six out
of six what will it take to catch uh
with that lady uh I mean I don't think
that really depends on me I think
with her or no I already lost
congratulations huge victory for you
we'll see you tomorrow thank you okay
our congratulations as well Rochelle
that's very very nice victory over a
tough competitor
um